the state of florida is teeming with
refugees from the northeast fleeing
tyranny and as mismanagement
but they're not the only ones in florida
florida's also
filled with pythons big snakes
slithering their way through the
everglades and messing with the food
chain
so how does the state of florida plan to
restore balance to its very fraught
ecosystem one man has thought a lot
about this and he has a really
interesting idea
his name is mike kimmel he's a trapper
known in florida as the python cowboy
and we're happy to have him on
tonight ms kimmel thanks so much for
coming on so what is
what is your plan to deal with the
overabundance of pythons in florida
well it's really not just my plan you
know a lot of people are involved with
it and
we we need a hunt and we need to remove
them and
the state right now has different
programs to do that
but uh we need more help you know we
need the general public involved
and uh you know we're doing everything
we can to try to incentivize that
so what one of the kind of core ethical
precepts of hunting is you eat what you
kill
do you eat python yes sir
absolutely and if i don't need it i
definitely make use of it you know you
can uh
can only eat so much snakes so you know
anything i don't eat myself
i feed to my different wildlife rescues
and livestock i have
huh i mean i it goes without saying it
tastes like chicken so i'm not even
going to ask you but tell me how hard it
is to hunt to python and how dangerous
it's definitely not easy it's a labor of
love you know it's something you you got
to be passionate about
something you know to kind of have
motivation for i generally go out there
for
three to five days at a time i'm
sleeping in the swamp
and i'm hunting these invasive snakes
either by boat
or in my customized truck where i'm
driving these levees that stretch out
into the swamp
and i'm looking for these snakes while
they're hunting for our native wildlife
well looks like they're hunting for you
or i'm watching video of blood all over
your arm you got bitten by a python what
was that like
yeah you know sometimes the job gets a
little messy a little dangerous
and uh it's just a part of it uh
recently capturing a big
almost 18-foot python 135 pounds
and uh it struck at me i was able to
dodge it strike but it
gave me another quick half strike i
wasn't expecting
these older snakes they're smart they
know what they're doing and uh
it got me pretty good on my arm actually
um got a couple main veins
i think it just missed an artery but uh
i had a little bit of a gusher coming
out of my arm
where's that snake now
here's the uh the one that got me but uh
i ended up getting her
that's amazing what kind of firearm do
you use for for python hunting
um generally i'm just using my hands uh
i i capture them alive for me that
that's the safest way and the most
humane way to do it
it's it's a lot harder to shoot a snake
directly in the brain than you think
it is and generally these snakes they're
they're not scared of anything they
think they're camouflaged you know
they're the top predator
and i'm able to sneak up on them grab
them and uh once i grab them you know
they're not going anywhere
it's uh becomes a wrestling match but
thankfully
i get i get the better of them damn well
it's sporting anyway no one deer hunts
like that though i would recommend a 308
that's just me
but i'm very impressed mike kimmel it's
great to see you tonight good luck
good luck thank you so much